hallo leute ich begrüße euch heute zu
einem ganz besonderen video zusammen mit
unseren partnern von easy languages
machen wir in dieser woche ein projekt
und zwar beschäftigen wir uns mit
redewendungen insgesamt zwölf sprachen
nehmen daran teil und alle von uns
machen ein video über eine redewendung
oder einen ausdruck den es in ähnlicher
form in ganz verschiedenen sprachen gibt
die redewendung die wir uns ausgesucht
haben für dieses projekt ist eigentlich
ziemlich brutal sowie viele deutsche
redewendungen die noch aus dem
mittelalter stammen und auch heute noch
in der deutschen sprache manchmal
benutzt werden und zwar ist dass die
redewendung jetzt ist das kind schon in
den brunnen gefallen
und das bedeutet so viel wie jetzt ist
es schon passiert jetzt kann man daran
nichts mehr ändern
gott klar die es ist etwas schreckliches
passiert man hat alle unsere videos aus
unserem youtube-channel gelöst was wie
kann das denn sein
du hast mir ja schon seit wochen gesagt
wie soll das passwort stark machen und
das habe ich leider nicht dazu gekommen
du hast das nicht er macht ja nicht
vergessen ich bin nicht dazu gekommen
aber jetzt wird es richtig zeit
ja jetzt ist das kind doch schon den
brunnen gefallen ja wie viele andere
redewendungen auch die heute noch in der
deutschen sprache benutzt werden
kommt auch diese redewendung vermutlich
aus dem mittelalter
denn da dort gab es noch so offene
brunnen in den dörfern und vermutlich
sind da ab und an mal leute hinein
gefallen und es gibt auch alte schriften
in denen die redewendung damals noch
hieß den brunnen erst schließen wenn das
kind schon hineingefallen ist oder wenn
das kind schon ertrunken ist klingt sehr
brutal und komischer weise benutzt man
das auch heute noch immer dann wenn man
sagen möchte dass man jetzt etwas tut
oder eine maßnahme ergreift obwohl es
eigentlich schon zu spät ist
das interessante ist dass es auch in
vielen anderen sprachen redewendungen
und idiopathische ausdrücke gibt die
dafür stehen dass etwas passiert ist
dass man jetzt nicht mehr ändern kann
und wir haben mal unsere partner von
easy languages gebeten solche
redewendungen in ihren sprachen für uns
aufzunehmen und die seht ihr jetzt
[Musik]
was lafita jetzt möchten wir euch
unbedingt einladen
auch die anderen videos auf den anderen
easy languages kanälen anzusehen wie ihr
wisst gibt es unser projekt mittlerweile
in vielen sprachen als easy raschen sieg
riesig atalan oder sogar easy zur heli
mittlerweile und all diese anderen
sprachen haben ähnliche videos
produziert wo sie auch redewendungen
erklären und miteinander vergleichen
dass heißt ihr seht dann auch immer eine
deutsche redewendung von mir aufgenommen
auf den anderen kanälen guckt euch das
mal an die playlist findet ihr hier
unten in der infobox danke fürs zu sehen
und bis bald
[Musik]